okay that should be where you go
you should not go into the
demoralization we gotta get past
that okay we're going to
learn what work has to be done by seeing
where i cannot work
where i cease to function and so it's
going to take you back to your basics of
course
but you are learning things more than
your basics and as i always say
your basics are actually part of the
problem
okay um so we're going to go back to the
to the live environment with the control
device and his
grip is predetermined okay
and we're also going to predetermine
that he has a
spinal displacement kind of pressure
okay
and we'll keep in there what we were
doing last time
so uh i am not going to predict before
he touches me
my technique i'm also of course
going to practice uh the
non-contestation of my jiu jitsu
so i'm not going to force the technique
i'm going to harmonize or reconcile yin
yang at all time but we're going to add
to that now
okay some some strategic elements
one is that within his
first to second step he is either
tilting
or i'm in the back okay so that would
make this
wrong one two he hasn't tilted till
three four
that would be wrong that will not
translate into a more live environment
so i could go here one i'm in the back
or of course okay
okay i got i got two steps in which i'm
no longer in front of him
or his spine is already tilting okay
um second one any throw that you do
it can't be a momentum throw
so i'm not going to go like this
there has to be some spinal displacement
i'm sorry some base of support
displacement
do you see that because that will
not not never translate into a live
environment
but it's low percentage okay
um do you understand what i mean by that
so
i'm not gonna go uh here and
he takes his role
i have to have some technique where i
take out
his base okay i either
com move it in a different vector
than his line of gravity or i prevent it
from moving with his line of gravity
does that make sense
okay so those those are my goals
as i go along
a lot of times you can do this with a
coke projection it doesn't always have
to be that you're taking audrey's face
okay so he's pushing
okay okay
so um the question is
how do i not a momentum throw
and here i'm defining a momentum throw
where his line of gravity and his base
of support
are traveling along the same vector okay
so he's pretty mobile flexible strong
athletic
um let's just have you run out okay as
best you can maybe you land on your face
or
or whatever okay so we're gonna go here
and i'm know you see
okay so i have a couple choices
but all i have to do is make sure that
his line of gravity
and his face of support are not
traveling along the same vector
so first i have two means of doing that
the first means
is i stop his space of support
it doesn't travel with designer so it
can be on the same vector
but i don't allow it to go the second
means is i actually make the base of
support travel
on a different vector okay then
for each of those ways i have two ways
of doing it as well
i can either
block or displace his base of support
with my base of support
or i can coqject his
base of support onto a different vector
okay
so we'll be going i do got to do that
same technique
and when he comes around i step one so i
stepped on my heart
i step inside of his base
till i stop his bases support from
continuing
on with it this is a good one to know
when the guy turns
into you really sharp so he turns in
really sharp and then you step in
the other one is i'll do the coq
projection
and his head will go this way but his
hips
will go that way you see okay so we're
doing
the technique and i should never have a
rep where he just would like that
i'm always going to deal with that
basically
[Applause]
okay here we go half positioning is also
key so this is not martial this is why
we handcuff people so they lose their
martial ability
okay so you should have awareness of
your hands
never been in the same plane okay
especially two planes but
here are three planes i have going
height width and depth they're in the
same plane
so i always have a sense
of covering my outer rim
in different planes okay so when i'm
doing
a tenshi nugget you see different planes
they come around different planes
don't let them tie it again
never like this do not translate
you need to have an awareness of
covering your body and he's throwing
lots of stripes
and you're covering your body so you can
do your thing
always covered
till first step
how how do i put him in well i have a
inward spiral at the outer spine like
oh straight places
even more awkward
okay don't put your hands together it's
not marshall
no okay somewhere you are finding this
is this part here same thing
basic support line of gravity on the
same line
so just run out of it
you see so again i have the same thing i
can
have his i have to have his base of
support and
going in different directions so his i
can have his center going
forward then it'll work
because this center is going that way
when i pull this top down
okay so some other options
i'm in here and i thought off sir
i find this base again so around
boom one more time
it's just like cooking a hole you'll
find his face here boom
or let go let go
of the arm here you see hey you come in
here full
of space again okay so at this speed
um i want you to understand that
it's very uh it's not as
easy to have his center going
in that direction because it's a slow
training
and so you're actually feeling for the
wrong
thing when you can tell that their
center is not going away from there
a line of support you have to be able to
feel that
so that you would not do what what i'm
seeing
do you see you would know i'm going to
need
to disrupt displace or de-vector his
base of support
do you get it so it's if if you're going
full speed
and the guy is going through wow you
might be able to get the cochlear nugget
but
at the slow speed that we're doing and
in guwaza
that is the wrong technique because you
don't have your center going through
so you're training yourself incorrectly
so
yes this is the key hon but this
that little thing is not real it will
not help you
you should be able to tell that so you
have to find
the the other things that you're doing
in here
see okay let's go okay so
you have some techniques where you have
uh bent the guy on his waist
as opposed to tilt him okay
oh wait techniques where the guys bent
over
his energy went here so his energy
should keep going forward
otherwise he won't be a yin yang
reconciliation
so now i go like this and then
i try to shout him back up so i could
take him backwards
that would be a uh one it's contestation
and it's not
young reconciliation so you have to
watch
that especially when you put your hands
together for pokemon
you haven't bent over and now you're
trying to get him to come forward
to go backwards you see that's the no no
same thing goes on uh
oh you did the position you bind him
forward
you see and then you're trying to get
him to go
first that's a no-no
now in chi wasa he has no prescription
to do a reaction in kihon maza
i guess if you want to do what-if
training you could say
a guy's bent over and then he goes ahead
and see regain his height
okay so maybe maybe you're doing uh if
not
he bends over and then you go okay what
do i do
i'm trying for uh kaiten but he stood
back up
oh okay then i go to the what if train
but in guwaza he has no prescription
placed upon him so if he's bending over
and energy is going forward she should
just keep going forward
okay so if i'm doing uh
i have the one where i don't bend them
forward
but sometimes there's a lot of momentum
that's going
a lot of momentums that go on that way
that's where your tent concludes
you see and then you have to crush your
center
so i'll show you what that is so
i'm coming around won't and i drop him
and then i catch him coming up if he
doesn't want to come up
then that's where i come into my other
technique
but the whole time i'm not going to make
him go
down and then try to get him to come up
so i'm coming in here well he bent down
on me
don't try to shovel him back up find
your different find your different
techniques and just open it back up
boom
well next thing i want you to pay
attention to is
we're now going to go to this weird
thing
because we're not trying to do
techniques you got it
this is still energy energy that's
crossing
okay
so if you feel like at first anyway
it's because you're stuck in forms okay
it's still just energy energy is coming
in
feel the energy okay
let's go okay it's just a mind trick
it's just like a koan
it's it's it's your stuff on form that
you don't see the
the technique really what is let's say
he only grabs one of those at a time
what is that you see so really i get a
choice of which close to dirty i want
you're going to come around and do it
you see
right all right and then you can also
uncross you could uh uncross the thing
so i come around this is
it's only crossed because your mind is
crossed okay
of course you since you have the cause
of dirty you you kind of ignore the
hands right and you're in here
so let's look at giugi nagio or it would
be coconutty going forward and where's
the base displacement on that
so his leg is gonna step
in the throat and my pushy is gonna go
on this stop
my is going to go boom and kick
that leg out
so again i don't i don't want a momentum
throw
or he's ahead of me because he'll just
walk out of it
so i stop his face
displace his face with your face okay
here we go
okay so uh the original control device
was the iota-doty and spinal
displacement
okay but some of you are
now taking away one of our control
devices
in that's a no-no because we're working
on our particular thing
and jiwaza let's use it as an
opportunity
to feel when the technique has changed
because it's
because the opening has been countered
uh
you're gonna this will be foreign to you
because you usually do what you're told
but you're gonna turn away from
detective turn
there you go you see now he's not doing
the second prescription
so you're you're going to try to do this
technique he turns on you you this is a
no no
this technique is not here this is not
where
um any of the back outer kazushi
patterns are
the back our kazushi patterns have the
guy's base going forward
forward forward he can't
turn it so anyone who turns it
it's not going forward they're
countering that the movement
so you have to feel that okay so i go
and he turns on me right you have to
feel that technique
you don't keep trying to do
tenshi nage kokuhol it got counter
got you guys got it okay so
i'm trying for my technique you'll feel
it you just goes in on you
just goes in on you just go around right
you have the same base
same base problem
so out here you turn okay keep going
around come in
find the base displace it okay here we
go